so the point is the essential thing you
need to build a CPU and with that you
can actually build a CPU and get your
instructions from memory because you can
point to them you can get you data
because you can point to them but if
you've got something else you can you
can be really clever you can build
things that are quite cool and the other
thing is this idea of a subroutine let's
just think about what a program is a
program is a set of instructions that
are going to execute or a routine for
doing something so you routine it's just
the instructions you're going to execute
to do something that might be to say
calculate Fibonacci might be to add
numbers together it might be sort of
played the latest game and you could
write that as just one long sequence of
instructions perhaps with the odd loop
that would jump back and so on and you
could do that in assembly and C in Java
and c-sharp in Objective C whatever
language you want to choose certainly
have a procedural object knowledge is
sort and write your whole program how
they won't go but if that's all you've
got you're prone becomes long you might
be able to jump between different points
which can help but you'll often find you
writing the same bit of code time and
time again so let's say you want to just
print a character out and that might be
done on some machines by writing to a
certain location in memory use a pointer
and write to it now if you have to write
that code lots and lots of times you're
going to get pretty bored of writing it
it's gonna be the same thing so it's
born to write chances are you talking
the same code again you're gonna get
bored of writing it seem more likely to
make a mistake seem more likely to
introduce bugs and so it doesn't work so
the way we do loop in assembler is we
say jump to this location and we jump
back to a different point and it'll xq
the same bits of code time and again you
know the the point it says go to this
point and we add an offset or remove an
offset and we jump back so I can always
set it to an exact value doesn't matter
which depending on the machine so in
create loops and we can also jump to
other bits of code now the idea of the
subroutine is when you want to do
something say like printer character
rather than writing it many times you
write it once and you put it somewhere
in memory and you know the address of
where it is or you have something that
points to it thedress and then whenever
you want to print something
rather than putting the code in again
you just put in an instruction that says
jump to that part of the code that
prints something out and so you have
your main routine which is say doing
whatever it is you want to do and then
you have lots of these sub routines or
smaller routines that are going to do
parts of it that you just jumped in when
you need to print a character or read a
character or access the floppy disk or
whatever it is you want to do update
your OpenGL game so you just jump to
these subroutines oh and then you've got
an interesting problem how do you get
back from that subroutine because you
couldn't you could say okay I'll get to
the end of the instructions and I just
said okay I've got here how do I get
back well it's easy the first one says
I'll just jump back to the next
instruction but then you call it again
and you end up and you jump back up to
the wrong place so how do you get around
that issue that have you know where to
get back to can i try and guess god I
need to try and guess so in the
subroutine do you write in look at
such-and-such a registers to see where
to go back to so that's one way but what
you need to do first initialize that
register yeah so you say okay I'm gonna
jump from the main routine to the
subroutine and they can't just use a
normal jump there because that doesn't
remember what you got to go back to so
you have a special type of jump which as
well as jumping also memorizes the
address or a pointer to the next
instruction now just as you said if
you've got something like an ARM chip
and some like the Archimedes or the
recipe pie then that will store that
return address as it's called
in another register so it'll copy it
where it's got to go to into another
register you execute that code and then
you just set the instruction pointer or
the program counter to have the same
value that's in that or the register and
jump your back and you carry on
executing there just you build your CPU
to allow that
now there's problems with that because
if you want to implement something like
recursion you have a function which
calls the subroutine and that subroutine
is going to call itself so if you do
that you lose the original bit of code
is that right well you lose the original
return address so so straightaway we've
gone into a never-ending loop you're
going to do a never-ending loop or so it
gets messy in the prone crashes and
the things go wrong what most CPUs do or
on some other arm you implement yourself
because it's the way the arm works
and that's fine
is you store that return address in
memory via pointer so rather than having
a register that contains the return
address you can have a register and it's
usually done on the stack using the
stack pointer that actually points to
somewhere in memory where you store that
return address and then when you get
another one you can move on to another
bit of memory and store that on there
then you can ride back up your stack to
get the return addresses if I remember
professor Brailsford video well enough
the last thing on the stack is the first
kind of place you go yeah then that
would kind of come off the stat pop off
this yep I'm remembering it yeah that's
right
and pop off the stack and then give you
access to where the next pointer is so
if you think about it you sort of think
you imagine this piling pieces of paper
on top of each other
post-it note if you take the top placing
that off and then it tells you to go
back in then the next time it takes you
and so until you end up with the one
that gets you back into the main routine
so some CPUs like the x86 family that
started off with the 8088
will do that automatically so that when
you make that special jump to the
subroutine they will store the return
address on the stack for you others like
the ARM chip require you to store it in
register and then you have to put it on
the stack if you want to do is just the
architecture that is horses for courses
it doesn't make any real difference so
that's depending on how many
instructions the instructions just it's
just the design you think well actually
you're making you chip some more complex
by automating that whereas actually if
we just let the pro you're doing because
sometimes you don't need to do that you
can make your profile with those leaf
subroutines as they tend to be now and
so once you've got that technology
either part via software or part via the
city hardware and you can move it
between the two as much as you like then
you can use the subroutine to make the
code easier to write and from that you
can build functions and see procedures
methods and objects all the implement in
an object-oriented language are all
implemented in that way they using that
idea that subroutine so when you call
them they store the return address
and execute the code and then they have
some mechanism to get back from that
return address to what get back from the
end and subroutine via the return
address to where you carry on now the
clever thing is how they originally came
up with that idea because the original
CPUs something like EDSAC back in the
late 40s early 50s didn't support
subroutines in hardware and yet a chap
called David wheeler was able to create
what was called the wheeler jump which
he used to implement the very first
subroutines now this is really clever
but absolutely nightmarish and I should
put up a disclaimer but do not try this
at home because it used what's called
self-modifying code so let's get rid of
that let's use some sort of pseudo armed
code and we've got some instructions
that are going off and they're going to
jump to a subroutine we'll call this sub
and then we're going to carry on here
and then so we'd have a subroutine
somewhere off in memory and it would
have the instructions it would need to
execute and then at some point you're
going to get to a point here where you
have to return that's the way most
things are structured now we had jumps
and things on earth sack but that's all
we had so we can have a jump here that
would get back so we'd have a branch
here that would say branch and let's
just give it a label back but we don't
know where back is because we don't know
that until we actually call it so if we
know where the civil routine is and
because when we write the code we know
how many instructions there are here we
can work out where in memory this branch
back instruction is going to be branch
two back and so this is where the clever
bit happens what David wheeler did will
say okay before we make this branch or
jump to the subroutine we're going to
put in instructions here which and we're
using some really clunky pseudocode
modify jump back so you had codes and
modified itself as it was running and it
would alter this instruction to remove
back there and put in let's just call it
return and modify that to be returned
and then a bit later on we call again so
we'd modify the jump here what if I jump
back call the subroutine we branch to it
then we will carry on here and we call
this let's call it Fred and so we
replace return here with the address of
Fred so that's now pointing to Fred so
that when the subroutine is called it
excuse and then jumps back to the right
place so something about the ability to
jump to an address in your CPU and the
ability to modify memory by monkeying
around we're using a pointer you could
implement a subroutine even though the
CPU didn't have any support for it now
this is what's called self-modifying
code because the program is running is
changing itself as it is running if you
get this wrong the program crashes and
bad things happen so that's lots what
you want to do for fell apart which is
why this technology is then moved into
the CPU and implemented in hardware for
the same reason if something's we're
going to do a lot off so let it be
implemented once and we reuse it in the
same way that we going to do lots of
things in our program so we make a
server routine to do that and rather
this is so common we put it into the
hardware because we're gonna use it or
at least some sort of hardware support
for it and of course the way modern CPUs
have got with caches and things in there
self-modifying code doesn't work
properly anyway because they're not true
von Neumann machines based on my pre
trained network I'm going to produce
five thousand characters of random text
and let's see what it looks like
so we'll just boot up for a minute and
then it will run it's pretty quick once
it gets going there we go so you can see
we've got comments we've got replies at
first glance it looks plausible when you
actually read into the comments they're
very bizarre so this guy by blocky
thought now that might be a real person